dormir dormir un peu plus pour 80 2 %
des français le principal bénéfice de
l'application des 35 heures c'est de
pouvoir se reposer un peu plus mais
parmi les salariés qui bénéficient de ce
passage aux 35 heures nombreux sont ceux
qui profitent de ce temps libre
supplémentaire pour s'adonner à des
activités nouvelles et parmi les plus
prisés le sport et le bricolage
medhi leroy et dominique marault tels
qu'ils ont l'air de souffrir mais ils
ont tous payé pour ça les accros gros
biceps et la taille barbie les clubs de
remise en forme en accueille de plus en
plus je filais plus tôt
et donc comme je finis vers entre 17h et
18h donc ça me permet de venir ici faire
du sport et si vous n'aviez pas eu les
35 heures vous seriez pas inscrites
probablement pas comme 5% des nouveaux
adhérents
horaires allégés journée de repos
supplémentaire grâce aux 35 heures on
peut prendre soin de soi et entretenir
sa ligne bien avant 18 heures
on a augmenté le nombre de cours dans la
semaine et on les a placés à des heures
où on n'avait pas l'habitude de déplacés
et finalement on a des pros qui sont
dans le jargon remplit tout au long de
la journée
ça fait 14 mm donc là vous avez un
là une autre gymnastique nous ne sommes
pas à l'école mais dans un stage aux
parquets dans un grand magasin de
bricolage à ce que le problème les
élèves sont nombreux et attentif
objectif utiliser le temps libre à
manier le marteau et la perceuse
j'ai l'intention de bricoler de
continuer mes collections de faire des
tas de choses du sport j'en profite et
deux jours par mois
du coup les directeurs des magasins se
frotte les mains le bricolage décidément
tout le monde s'y met selon un sondage
ipsos 74% des français comptent utiliser
leur nouveau temps libre à bricoler et
le rayon qui profitent le plus de cet
engouement
c'est la décoration tous les produits
tendances les produits faciles les gens
au plus en plus de temps aux envies de
se sentir bien chez de ce type de
produits les peintures les choses
faciles à faire aménager son chez soi on
remue et ensemble quel que soit le choix
des français des secteurs de l'économie
profitent des 35 heures mais attention
pour près de 80% de salariés temps libre
signifie tout simplement quelques heures
de plus sous la couette
alors peggy l'euro